now one of the things that you have been
hearing from Modi is just how well India
is doing in comparison to China is it
fair to look at those two economies as
competing with each other because they
seem to be well I don't know about
directly competing as opposed to
competing for the title of you know the
next great hope for the world economy
and I do think that there despite the
somewhat negative report we just heard
there are hopes that the payoff to
Modi's reforms will take some time but
ultimately occur and that the growth
path in India is promising it's
happening at this you know at the same
time as the Chinese growth rate is
coming down one big concern for both
countries is whether the growth that
we've seen in both countries which has
been much higher than the global average
reverts to the mean over the next 20 or
30 years which is what has happened in
general on average across countries in
historically if that were to occur
there's a big missing piece for the
global growth equation out over the next
you know yes in China did you see the
desperation there Russia charme over
Morgan Stanley uses our desperation is
it renew sweat to the economy because
they're not getting it done at 7% GDP I
think I would say more widespread
recognition that growth in the future is
gonna be noticeably lower than it was
yes so we get you in trouble for the
number on it this morning
well wait the official number or the
real number the Peter Orszag founders
yeah well fishel statistics or the real
number um and that's partly because
they're they're hitting what's called
the Lewis turning point when you move
workers from agriculture to
manufacturing no longer adding to
productivity they've got to invest more
in total factor productivity they're
trying to do that they're trying to
upgrade their universities and their
academic systems that's crucial to
growth they've got to avoid the back
over from the housing crisis there are a
lot of challenges